comment inciter les fabricants en faire
plus en matière de durabilité comme on
convaincre les consommateurs de réparer
plutôt que de racheter on en parle avec
vous Enrique Martinez bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
directeur général du groupe Fnac Darty
on l'a vu c'est un indice de
réparabilité il était mis en place par
le gouvernement il est obligatoire
depuis 2021 je me demandais est-ce que
vous l'affichez vraiment tout le temps
dans vos magasins sur votre site parce
qu'on était juste avant avec
l'association alt à l'obsolescence
programmée qui nous disait que tous les
vendeurs tous les distributeurs ne
faisaient pas vous le fait tout le temps
chez fenêtre
il sait très bien parce que même avant
en 2018 grâce à eux il y avait comme des
Amis de la Terre on avait commencé à
s'intéresser au sujet de la réparabilité
il avait créé nos propres anti-céré par
altés sur le monde de l'ordinateur entre
autres on trouve que c'est un élément
indispensable aujourd'hui pour donner
une formation juste consommateur et
c'est devenu un des arguments principal
d'achat des produits et est-ce que tous
les fabricants parce que c'est ça dépend
de puisqu'il se note et ce qui joue le
jeu est-ce qu'il vous transmettent leur
note aujourd'hui les fabricants ils sont
très sensibles à des éléments qui sont
clés pour ces consommateurs et c'est un
élément qui a quelques années
probablement ça aurait été éviter parce
que c'était moins confortable et parler
des sacs et parler de l'innovation de la
technologie mais aujourd'hui ils ont
compris et particulièrement en France
parce qu'il y a un sensibilité il y a la
législation qui est beaucoup plus
avancée que dans d'autres pays au monde
qui sont l'intérêt des alignés à la
France parce que ça va devenir tendance
mondiale donc oui ils sont en train de
jouer les jeux qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on fabriquant Rick et Martinez
nous vous fournit pas la note d'un
produit est-ce que vous le retirez de
l'étal du rayon comme la loi le prévoit
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence que on
peut pas accepter des terribles de la
loi donc oui évidemment mais c'est pas
le cas et nous avons si ça devait
arriver si ça arrive on les faits mais
aujourd'hui nous on fait on joue avec
des acteurs mondiaux responsables et on
faisait des sélections la sélection ça
sert à ça aussi pas seulement aussi un
très bon produit mais les bons
comportements de nos partenaires et ils
vont jouer les jeux j'ai totalement
confiance à eux bon vous l'avez dit à
demi-mots chefs Darty cet indice vous ne
l'avez pas attendu vous l'avez précédé
vous l'avez même un petit peu inspiré
donc avec le labo Fnac c'est ça tout à
fait et la voix flag c'est intéressant à
la performance des produits on est quand
là 2018 c'est ça 2018 et on a commencé
on me souviens qu'on avait fait un
visite avec quelques journalistes pour
les montrer les tripes d'un ordinateur
en fait nos équipes du labo nos
techniciens nous expliquer la différence
de temps et des et des faisabilité
d'échanger un batterie qui était inséré
dans 4 Liars et qui s'apprenait une
heure et demie à les sortir ou un
ordinateur qui était impossible d'ouvrir
et donc il est pas réparable et que ça
c'était plus acceptable alors on va voir
comment vous cherchez chez Fnac Darty
accompagner les consommateurs qui
veulent être plus responsables vous avez
plusieurs outils on va les passer un
petit peu en revue il y a le baromètre
SAV qu'on retrouve sur sur Internet
c'est une espèce de palmarès des
produits qui sont les plus fiables et
les plus réparables ouais en fait on a
trouvé qui a une mine d'or depuis des
années parce que comme vous savez on
répare plus de 2 millions des produits
par an et donc on a l'information
prédictive de tout ce qui peut arriver
en produit c'est à disquement et c'est
l'information qui est très riche qui
n'utilise pour nous sur les choix de nos
produits la destruction avec nos
fabricants mais qu'on n'avait jamais
partagé avec les consommateurs et on a
dit au contraire donner on va la
partager il faut la partager il faut on
est dans le monde de la donnée du Data
c'est data c'est une data qui hyper
riche et hyper propre donc on va donner
la chance à tous les marques des jouets
positifs pour améliorer son escort et ça
nous permet à nous d'avoir un émulation
positive et aux marques des faire des
efforts qui payent et en quoi ce
baromètre il se différencie de l'indice
de réparabilité du gouvernement est-ce
que votre baromètre va peut-être plus
loin que l'indice il va un peu plus loin
la fiabilité la robustesse du produit
voilà nous on va chercher tous nos
statistiques sur le stabilité des
produits après on va intégrer la
dimension des disponibilités pièces
détachées c'est à dire que pour réparer
un produit d'abord il faut qu'il tombe
en panne très souvent
les pièces il faut qu'il soit disponible
vraiment et dans la durée et après on va
s'intéresser aussi aux choses des prix
des pièces parce qu'en fait tout ça doit
être son ensemble il faut que la
réparation soit possible et
économiquement viable pour tout le monde
ok il y a un deuxième outil il faut
qu'on en parle aussi qui est à
disposition des consommateurs c'est
l'étiquette choix durable on a trouvé en
magasin et l'idée c'est de mettre en
valeur un champion dans sa catégorie
c'est intéressant ça et c'est
intéressant parce que ça ramène aux
produits et en fait je comprends une
catégorie quand les grosses
électroménagers qui nous vient
rapidement à l'esprit on en parle des
réparations aujourd'hui c'est les
premiers critères de choix d'un
consommateur face à un rayon des
produits en électroménager d'autres
catégories pété de savoir arriver en
deux ou un 3 parce que c'est design etc
mais faut électroménager la question
c'est pour combien de temps ça va durer
chez mois et donc un a dit c'est à
l'information qui est relevante pour le
consommateurs de son choix il faut créer
ces étiquettes des choix durables donc
si je suis consommateur et que chez
Darty j'ai deux affichages et l'indice
de réparabilité du gouvernement et j'ai
l'étiquette choix durable c'est pas un
peu confusant c'est pas compliqué pour
le client de s'y retrouver c'est le
vendeur qui va faire les critères juste
c'est à l'information qui est Darty
enfin Darty à fourni avant le marché où
on n'a pas attendu avoir ses baromètres
tant mieux que ça arrive ça va permettre
de mettre tout le monde sur les mêmes
créneaux mais j'ai confiance mes
vendeurs sont capables des données du
sens à tous ces informations qui sont
pas contradictoires ça peut être même
complémentaire et ce baromètre
cette étiquette donc c'est des destiné
en la compris au consommateurs après on
revient en fabricant et je reviens à ma
question est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils font des efforts non
pas sur leur note mais est-ce qu'il
propose des produits qui sont ben voilà
plus plus réparables plus robustes il y
a une tendance vraiment tout à fait et
en fait ils ont pas des choix parce que
dès lors qu'ils sont mal placés dans ces
escorts représente des marques il
commence à avoir un problème des accès
au marché parce que nous en tant
déjà les consommateurs mais je pense que
celles qui traînent les pieds vont
comprendre et ça paye pas trop ils vont
être obligés on le voit dans les design
des produits il y a une forte
amélioration cette dernière temps pour
rentrer les produits plus réparables et
plus accessibles en fait dans les
designs de produits qu'elle est sujet de
la réparation qui est beaucoup mieux
pris en compte qui avant et puis les
sujets de rentrer le poulet plus fiable
et là nous on contribue avec tous nos
données statistiques pour un feedback
régulière pour les advertir que certains
design particulières ils ont eu peu
provoquer des dysfonctionnements chez
les clients parfois c'est pas de
dispensément technique en soi c'est
mauvais utilisation des produits du
client fait particulièrement d'avoir un
impact et ils sont l'intérêt de corriger
en tout cas ce qui nous concerne à nous
les produits qui sont les moins virtueux
on arrive à les sortir de nos catalogue
voilà je pense qu'à la motivation
intéressante pour les faire vous assumez
de sortir des catalogues si le produit
n'est pas assez dur à ce n'est pas assez
réparable ou bien des sortir un
abonnément illimité des réparations qui
s'appelle Darty max donc en fait on est
intéressé à que les produits tombent
parce que on est responsable pour les
réparer donc c'est pas comme avant que
vous dire en fait vous êtes intéressé
que les produits tombent en panne parce
que vous allez faire du bénéfice
aujourd'hui j'ai fait des je fais pas
des bénéfices si vous prenez dans ma
base c'est moi qui va les réparer
gratuitement vous avez lancé vous en ai
parlé de ce service d'abonnement
réparation limitée qu'une prise en
charge à 100% de la réparation de tous
les produits qui sont des produits
vendus par la maison est-ce que vous
voyez Martinez un engouement de la part
des clients pour ça parce que j'ai vu
que pour 2023 votre objectif c'était 2
millions d'adhérents pour 2023 on y sera
ou pas bah on n'est pas loin on est dans
la trajectoire
donc
on n'est pas encore dans les moments de
bizarre de bilan annuel ça va arriver
dans quelques dans quelques semaines
mais
je pense que bientôt j'espère pouvoir
inviter mes partenaires pour fêter les
premiers million et après il viendra la
deuxième et après on va continuer
aujourd'hui une deuxième mission sera en
2023 ou plus tard on verra bien mais
déjà on va faire nos engagements des
deux mais en fait que l'on a sorti les
programmes il paraissait impossible
parce que les choses de la réparation
c'est pas au quotidien des clients
aujourd'hui et en plus avec la crise
c'est l'inflexion ça devient encore plus
pertinent parce que tout le monde a vide
et faire des économies aussi donc si
j'ai bien compris on finit là-dessus
vous êtes en train de de faire évoluer
votre modèle votre business model
comment dire en anglais chef Darty
est-ce que vous prenez pas un risque
parce que qui dit plus de réparation dit
moins de vente
donc faut que l'abonnement d'artimax
qu'on pense peut-être une baisse des
ventes si les gens rachètent pas
puisqu'il réparent regarde plus
longtemps ses vertueux d'un point de vue
écologique mais honnêtement il y a une
prise de risque chez Fnac Darty la vie
c'est un risque mais je pense qu'il faut
être dans l'heure du temps la modernité
aujourd'hui s'accompagner les clients
comme Darty je il a toujours fait la
franchise accompagné pour des produits
plus ses qualités il y a un service qui
accompagne les clients dans la durée ces
dernières années on a vu arriver dans
notre métier beaucoup des mondes qui a
porté pas la brique service mais que les
consommateurs ils sont acceptés à avoir
une vente sans service je pense que
demain ça sera plus les cas donc même si
globalement les marchés ne pourra faire
moins de volume je pense que des
secteurs engagés qui proposent des
services probablement ils auront un pas
des gâteaux un peu important en tout cas
c'est mon objectif c'est pas forcément
que j'ai vu à vendre moins c'est que les
marchés faire un problème moins des
volumes inutiles des volumes plus des
qualités soutenables et que nous et pour
un autre collègues qui vont prendre les
mêmes schémas que nous en bas faire une
partie du marché un peu plus importante
merci pour cet entretien Rick et
Martinez le directeur général du groupe
Fnac Darty
[Musique]